[Música]
na produção frutas que cai no chão no
transporte de grãos são sopradas ao
vento no mercado legumes que apodrecem
na geladeira estragou vai para o lixo e
assim o que era belo real vai dando
espaço ao invisível
essa cena que eu via quase três anos
atrás ela mudou o rumo da minha vida
quando eu olhei pra esse mamão toda a
minha vida toda tudo que eu já tinha
feito passou na minha cabeça naquele
momento então eu queria começar a falar
com vocês contando um pouquinho do que
dentro de mim faz esse lado de fora
melhor
eu tive uma infância de muita imaginação
eu queria ser astrônomo uma e eu queria
ser lixeira e eu passava muito tempo no
quintal da minha avó aprendendo sobre as
plantas que curam e navegando por
aqueles espaços conhecendo mais e mais
essas plantas e o poder que a natureza
tem na adolescência eu tive muita
preocupação com o lado social eu lia
muito trabalhei num albergue noturno
isso me fez entender o que é essa
situação de vulnerabilidade também
escreveu livros em braille
então consegui entender muito esse lugar
de pessoas que falta algum sentido
outros precisam se expandir quando fui
estudar
fui fazer física com iniciação
científica em astrofísica o céu sempre
me atraiu sempre sempre
mas aí chegou um momento que eu percebi
que as leis do universo não tavam
explicando tudo pra mim vou me voltei
pra valer para as leis dos homens foi
fazer direito
estudei direito trabalhei em muitas
empresas
a área jurídica depois na área editorial
e até o dia que eu cair naquele mamão e
quando eu vi aquele mamão eu entendi que
o belo da vida é a gente se aproximar
mais e mais num conceito mais
minimalista é agente sorver a fruta por
inteiro é a gente entender cada parte
zinha das coisas da vida né e dá valor
dá valor para tudo aquilo que a gente
tem nesse conceito de minimalismo é que
eu acho que a gente encontra plena
felicidade
mas voltando lá por uma mão eu estava em
casa ea gente resolveu fazer geléia eu e
meu filho e aí foi com pedro no ceagesp
caminhando no ceagesp eu começo a ver
pilhas de mamão e abacaxi de manga
absolutamente jogadas e largadas ou na
frente dos box ou nas caçambas ao lado e
aquilo me incomodou profundamente porque
naquele momento caiu pra mim como se
tivesse deslanchado um castelo mesmo
toda essa noção de certo e errado de
próprio próprio de bonito e feio virou
estranha porque aquele mão eu teria
minha casa e tava ali no lixo ou poderia
servir para alimentar tanta gente estava
ali no lixo
e aí a gente concebeu o comida invisível
que é um projeto de educação e
conscientização de combate ao
desperdício de alimentos
mas como ninguém faz nada sozinho eu
tenho dois sócios nesse projeto que é o
sérgio ea flávia ea gente tem muitos e
muitos anjos que emprestam asas ao
comida invisível para que ele possa
alçar vôo os agente entender o
desperdício de alimentos
a gente tem que perceber que a gente
está falando de algo que é da escassez
na abundância e porque eu falo que
desperdício de alimentos é escassez na
abundância porque se a gente for pensar
um país como o brasil por isso
lembro é um país de muita abundância lá
atrás quando pero vaz de caminha chega
no brasil ele já fala das abundância das
águas que têm em se plantando tudo dá
ou seja o brasil é farto o brasil é
próspero existe nas músicas está muito
retratado por mais água no feijão a
gente é cordato por natureza a gente
gosta de receber e pra receber
eu acabo cometendo deslizes e vou
desperdiçando mais e mais e é o que
acontece com isso o desperdício virou um
problema do mundo inteiro
só que pra ele ser um problema do mundo
inteiro ele precisa ser um problema de
todo mundo cada um de nós nessa sala
desperdiça e os pequenos desperdícios
nossos vão contribuindo para o grande
desperdício e desperdício muitas vezes
porque porque eu elejo o belo eu
estetismo a existência então o que
acontece eu acabo e entendendo que uma
cenoura ela precisa ser uma cenoura
perfeita aquela que fica bonitinha na
gôndola se a cenoura nasce com duas
pernas
ela vai ser descartado ela já é
descartada no campo se ela chega pro no
entreposto ela também já é descartada ou
seja ninguém quer se tem algum
defeitinho no uma fruta ou legume uma
verdura ninguém quer cabeça de peixe dá
um belo pirão a maioria das pessoas joga
fora e aí o que vai acontecendo esses
todos esses desperdícios nossos vão
levando a um grande número o mundo
inteiro desperdiçam 1.3 bilhões de
toneladas de alimentos
isso significa que 30 por cento de tudo
que é produzido no mundo é descartado
sem nunca chegar na mesa de ninguém
alimentos bons e próprios que poderiam
alimentar muita gente
isso corresponde ao pib
da suíça que é um dos dez países mais
ricos do mundo
eu não tinha a menor idéia
não sei se alguém daqui dessa sala tem
talvez luís filipe é o que é um ponto 3
bilhões de toneladas de alimentos
e aí eu fui encher bongs e eu enchi 9
milhões e 300 mil ongs por ano é o que a
gente joga fora
metade disso mataria fome do mundo não
teria mais forma se eu puser todos esses
aviões um do ladinho do outro eles vão
dar 17 voltas em volta da terra é muita
coisa
no brasil isso não é diferente
o brasil desperdiça algo próximo de tv
15 milhões de toneladas de alimentos
existem 13 milhões de pessoas em
situação de vulnerabilidade no brasil e
se a gente considerar se que as pessoas
comecem dois quilos de alimentos por dia
o que é um exagero cada um de nós fica
super satisfeito com um quilo a gente a
alimentária 20 milhões de brasileiros ou
seja não haveria fome mas é claro que
esse alimentária tem toda uma questão aí
de tecnologia transporte logística
perecibilidade do produto e tudo mais
mas pra gente o principal aspecto dessa
questão do desperdício é um afastamento
do homem com a natureza o homem passou a
se sentir controlador e não parte da
natureza e quando a gente faz esse
deslocamento o que acontece eu acabo não
percebendo que aquilo não me conectando
com aquilo que está na minha mesa com
aquilo que está no meu prato eu esqueço
que alguém precisa ou planta que alguém
preciso regar preciso acolher preciso
transportar preciso cozinhar para chegar
ali e aí eu penso pô
no total satisfação não quero mais e
descarto
e aí vai gerando esse grande problema no
mundo que desperdício de alimentos é um
dos maiores problemas
o mundo e é uma questão de hábito o
desperdício é uma que é hábito é algo
que a gente faz naturalmente o cérebro
através da glândula basal ele comece ele
faz atividades automáticas então a gente
acorda todo dia a gente escova de dente
a gente tira carro da garagem sem nem
pensar é uma são operações super
complexas mas a gente não pensa nelas é
a mesma história a questão do
desperdício sair do desperdício é sair
de um hábito e por isso a gente elegeu a
educação como o principal aspecto pra
gente sair dessa questão do desperdício
então e se repensar
ele é muito importante porque se eu mudo
o mundo muda
então a gente faz várias atividades em
escolas empresas
a gente faz orientação de merendeiras
tudo isso pra levar um pouco de
orientação para aproveitamento integral
de alimentos e para reduzir mais e mais
descartes nas nossas redes sociais a
gente fala muito sobre isso e agora a
gente vai começar um treinamento a gente
não é treinamento não a gente vai com
criar com alguns alunos das etecs nas
escolas técnicas de são paulo a gente
vai poder falar com até 2 mil alunos são
144 horas de treinamentos que a gente
vai entender quais são as situações
daquele local ea gente vai construir
juntos projetos para levar para as
comunidades de combate ao desperdício de
alimentos e porque para que cenas como
essas
parem de existir isso é uma cena
corriqueira no ceagesp esse é um catador
ele vai ele pega o lixo
o comitê invisível ele começou com food
tranque que eu queria mostrar um vídeo
em um rápido pra vocês
[Música]
a gente pega o segmento de seu chefe
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a cada saída do tanque meia tonelada é
preparar de alimentos que são alimentos
que iriam ser descartados é preparada
metade disso vai pra fazer ações de
educação então numa grande praça ea
outra metade vai sempre uma comunidade
neste vídeo a comunidade era a
comunidade portelinha que é construída
onde antes era um lixão e pra gente
poder ter voz porque a gente sabe que o
desperdício é uma coisa grande é um
problema grande
a gente sabia que a gente não podia
fazer nada sozinho então a gente foi
procurar pessoas que abraçassem essa
causa conosco e se tornassem
embaixadores dela então pessoas
formadores de opinião aqui tem uma
pequena parte deles eles se engajam
junto com a gente dão as mãos e nos
ajudam a replicar todas as nossas
informações
as ações as questões ligadas à educação
e aí a gente tem mais de 3 milhões de
pessoas que podem ser impactadas graças
à voz desses nossos embaixadores desses
nossos anjos e uma outra parte pra gente
combater o desperdício é trabalhar com
questões relacionadas ao correto destino
aquilo que não é lixo não pode ir para o
lixo e pensando nisso em dezembro do ano
passado a gente lançou um aplicativo um
aplicativo que por geolocalização ele é
conecta de um lado quem tem alimentos
bons e próprios então hotéis
restaurantes supermercados que perderam
valor comercial com ongs causas e
pessoas que precisam desses alimentos
durante a navegação do aplicativo tanto
doador quanto o donatário eles passam
por um processo que tem as políticas de
boas práticas da anvisa então ali eles
sabem como armazenar
é como combater contaminação cruzada
enfim e está sendo muito bacana acho que
a gente tem tido o sucesso de vários
restaurantes aderindo à causa inclusive
de grandes chefs que também nos ajudam
muito
aí na questão do comando invisível e uma
outra questão é então se eu tenho um
alimento bom e próprio eu deveria doar
para pessoas em situação de
vulnerabilidade social ou por último
fazer compostagem mas jamais e para o
aterro porque se vai pro terro esse
material vai se decompor em gás metano
que é 20 vezes mais poluente que co2 na
atmosfera se despedir se de alimentos
fosse um país ele seria o terceiro país
mais poluente do mundo e pensando nisso
a gente lançou a composteira comida
invisível que é uma composteira elétrica
pra começar a criar essa se repensar né
esse novo hábito na vida das pessoas e
por que isso gente porque eu acredito
que chegará o dia que uma simples e
noutra observada com frescor
desencadeará uma revolução muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]